that's um yeah that's my dad and that's
my eldest so the last time Amanda Henry
saw her father Robert looking well in a
care home the country was locking down
against coronavirus he was quite a
character he was you know always joking
always singing
four weeks later he was dead with
covid-19 as the cause of death
so his ashes his ashes now sit in her
living room she blames the government's
decision to discharge people from
hospitals into Care Homes without
testing them for covid first
there were so many
failings
when they said that priority testing was
going to happen for elderly residents in
care that didn't happen that was not
happening
when they said they were putting this
steel ring around vulnerable people in
care homes that didn't happen at all
it's decisions like this at the coven
inquiry will examine starting with how
prepared or unprepared the country was
for a pandemic
there's one word that sums up the
pandemic for so many and that is the
word loss
my principal aim is to produce reports
and recommendations before another
disaster strikes the four nations of the
United Kingdom independent of the
government the inquiry will go on to
look at the political decisions made
during the pandemic and the impact on
the Health Care System hearings will
begin in Spring and the process is
expected to last several years costing
upwards of 80 million dollars but as
broad as the inquiry is there are gaps
say experts the socio-economic
consequences of locking down the country
the impact on education business
hospitality
uh that was simply not discussed in
government you would have thought that
the inquiry would be giving a razor
sharp Focus to that issue but there's no
indication at all that they're going to
look at what didn't happen which was to
get advice from experts about all these
these other issues two hundred thousand
people lost their lives to covert here
in the UK each one represented on this
memorial wall now the inquiry says that
those that suffered will be at the heart
of this process and to do that they're
going to listen to the accounts of tens
maybe hundreds of thousands of people
the aim to discover what could or should
have been done to reduce their suffering
Charlie Angela Al Jazeera London